hallöchen meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer weiteren
map vorstellungen und zwar durch die
letzte gta map vorstellungen wo ich auf
dem server von unilever und so hat euch
ja ganz gut gefallen deswegen dachte ich
mir ich zeig euch jetzt mal die boom
beach map von dem von der lieben
personell msc kay vor und deswegen habe
ich für euch heute vier maps davon
vorbereitet die ich euch jetzt einfach
mal vorstellen werde
die erste map die ich euch gerade zeige
ist die boom beach map in minecraft halt
alles nachgebaut einfach ohne gras ohne
irgendwelche gebäude drauf ohne
irgendwelche bei spielsachen wie man
etwas bauen kann sondern einfach nur
diese blieb ich denke jeder kenne scan
test ich habe ja sogar mal ein boom
beach video gemacht und ich bin doch
gerade in der 1.8 also im 88 ich sollte
einfach in der neben den chat rapper
werden ich meine man schaut immer von
hier drauf man hat nach vorne sodass
mehr kann dann da vorne so sein sind
schiffchen aufbauen und so und hat halt
hier diese berge die übrigens auch sehr
sehr schön gelungen sind finde ich sehr
sehr geil aus eventuell sogar mit dem
shader noch ein bisschen schöner weil
das dann so im nebel ist so ein bisschen
ja das sieht sogar noch ein bisschen
schöner mit damit ausfindig und so sieht
das ganze hat einfach aus also dass es
quasi jetzt diese map nummer eins in dem
download-link der und in der
beschreibung habt dass ihr euch
unbedingt download sollte weil ich weiß
nicht ich finde also evans titanic
deswegen das ist einfach ich finde es
ein schönes bauteam diesen cool drauf
und so deswegen das von den bei auch
diese gt r die ich euch vorgestellt habe
also das ist die map nummer eins die
beinhaltet quasi einfach nur das ganze
also kein gras oder keine gebäude und so
sieht das ganze halt aus also da hinten
dieses brachial große konstrukt der
berge und des flusses einfach und so
sieht schon mega nice aus einfach so mit
dem mit dem soll shader so auf
entfernung und hier vorne hat man dann
halt diesen steg wo dann diese dieses
brötchen liegt dann halt einfach hier
drin
womit man dann immer losfahren kann auf
irgendwelche auf irgendwelche kämpfe und
so das ist auf jeden fall erstmal so das
grundgerüst wasser aufgebaut haben und
jetzt kommt auch schon zu der zweiten
map die ich euch jetzt zeige uns war es
eine etwas andere auch auf dieser
grundbesitz aber auch von von nick aber
die haben noch etwas hinzugefügt das
zeige ich euch jetzt mal ist zwar ist
das einfach genau das gleiche nur da ist
auch noch das gras drauf also es ist
jetzt noch kein großer unterschied die
geilsten map werden einfach mit drei und
vier sein weil das einmal das ganze hier
mit den gebäuden sein wird und dann
nochmal davon beispiel web also wir
haben jetzt hier quasi einfach das
komplette gras drauf das sieht einfach
dann schon ein bisschen bewachsener
damit aus natürlich diese komplett
riesige steinwand und so hat man
natürlich auch immer noch und das sieht
einfach richtig cool dass ich glaube ich
mache das ganze jetzt mal einfach in
diesem modus hier ohne also einfach mit
f1 und hier ist jetzt quasi einfach der
unterschied dazu der ersten app ist
einfach das jetzt noch gras drauf ist
einfach damit das ganze wissen
bewachsene ausüben dass sie da halt
einfach auch cool aus mit dem soll
shader wenn das ganze dann halt hier so
ein bisschen am wählen ist vor allem
auch alter das gras wedelt hier so rum
da hilft uns leben lang darüber diese
große diese große bergstein wann das
immer noch die hüpfen islam das ist auf
jeden fall schon die nummer zwei die in
dem download mit enthalten ist und jetzt
kommen wir schon noch mal drei wo die
gebäude damit drauf sind okay freunde
eigentlich sollte in der map nummer drei
die gebäude mit drin sein
und wohin hatte ich das auch also das
war einfach quasi diese map pizzen wer
so ein bisschen flacher gehalten einfach
mit den gebäuden das sieht man auch wenn
man sich den download mal genau anschaut
aber irgendwie habe ich die wohl aus
versehen gelöscht oder nicht gemacht
jedenfalls habe ich beim app 3 bei mir
jetzt einfach genau die gleiche web
gerade das liegt an mir aber das ist
eigentlich auch nicht weiterspielen weil
in web wir werden halt genau diese
gebäude einfach nochmal in der perfekten
formation für rubys quasi einfach
dargestellt deswegen würde ich sagen
machen wir an dieser stelle einfach
direkt weiter mit fact mit pacmag nummer
vier in diesem download so da haben
wir's jetzt nämlich auch uns war es dass
sie ganz einfach das base example
einfach hier wir sehen hier schon so ein
paar gebäude wir haben hier bleiben hier
beispielsweise hier ist dieses diese
dieses schiff was ich euch gesagt gesagt
hatte mit diesen schiffen kann man ja
desto mehr schiffe man hat mit desto
mehr desto mehr flieger hey das
mannschaften bist du mehr schiffe du
hast mit dem desto mehr schiffe du hast
je mehr je mehr schiffe du hast desto
mehr bin ich behindert je mehr schiffe
du hast mit desto mehr leuten kannst du
den kampf ziehen ich hoffe das feld
grammatikalisch richtig und bereitet
nicht wieder irgendwie auf twitter bei
mir rum und ich hoffe da reitet nicht
wieder irgendwer bei twitter auf mir
damit ohne spaß bei den ganzen
fremdsprache nicht zur zeit lernen kommt
deutsch echt viel zu kurz ist jeden fall
dieses abo ship womit man selber auf
reisen gehen kann also ich hab selber
längere zeit nicht gespielt ich habe
daher darüber mal damals ein video
gemacht aber hier haben auf jeden fall
noch ein paar sachen da stehen überall
so ein paar minen einfach diese kleinen
teile dann haben wir da so ein paar
sachen wie beispielsweise kanone
wir haben hier die lager wir haben ganz
ganz viele sachen die es auf jeden fall
auch in dem boom beispiel fürs handy
gibt wenn ich hier einfach mal rum
fliege seht ihr wahrscheinlich schon
viele sachen die ihr auch candy haben
wir beispielsweise den schützen tun was
auch zur verteidigung dient da auch noch
mal sonne
ich glaube das ist der laser oder ich
bin mir gar nicht so sicher
dann haben wir hier diese das sind doch
sind das nicht diese statuen
ich glaube das sind so teile die man
bekommt wenn man einen gewissen grad an
leuten besiegt also wenn man so ein
bisschen erfahrener schon ist im camp
dann bekommt man solche statuen sorry
also ich will das spiel als echt nicht
mehr so lang und hab da nicht mehr so
viel ahnung von hathor damals man video
gemacht da könnt ihr euch auch sagen was
genau die geerntet habe ich glaube nicht
dass es ihr ist es elixir keine ahnung
ich möchte ja einfach nur die map hier
vorstellen und zeigen das ist einfach
richtig geil ist und ja das war's dann
noch einige schon ich wollte euch nur
sagen dieser download von von fonic
besteht quasi aus fünf verschiedenen
sachen einmal vier welten uns bei einmal
der welt hier ganz normal ohne gras an
diese welt mit diesem gras dann einen
einfach ganz viele gebäude aufgelistet
dass man jedes gebäude hier dieses
gebäude oder dieses gebäude oder das
hier oder dass da hinten oder dass da
oder dass da oder das oder sogar das
schafft da vorne werden einfach
aufgereiht so dass man sich das ganze
anschauen kann bei mir ist das wohl
irgendwie beschädigt oder so keine
ahnung dann ist da noch diese laut grad
dabei haben uns gerade befinden also ein
beispiel map die sonne base zum beispiel
beispielsweise exam bei mäßig beispiel
bewerbe war das ganze halt aussehen
könnte und dann ist da noch eine fünfte
sache dabei und zwar msc magix einfach
dafür für die ganzen leute also ich
nutze es gar nicht mehr ich hab's damals
mal genutzt aber mittlerweile ich gar
nicht mehr das damit dass man das dame
dann einfach sich in die eigene welt
reinbauen kann quasi das auf jeden fall
ganz cool da ist relativ viel drinnen im
download link ich habe euch den po rum
forum link in die beschreibung gepackt
dass er einfach mal schauen könnt ja wir
bieten das ganze aus die haben wir
übrigens auch immer diese passenden
abstand von diesem also ist ja immer so
wenn ich hier im gebäude hinrich und der
sand geht bis hierhin dann kann ich das
nächste gebäude erst daran richten das
kennt man glaube ich von diesen aufbau
spielen das haben wir hier halt auch
berücksichtigt also das ist auf jeden
fall mehr als nur detailreich finde ich
richtig cool und ich finde freunde wenn
das keinen download verdient hat dann
weiß ich auch nicht also ich hab euch
jetzt diesem apple vorgestellt das war
es von meiner vorstellung wenn ihr sagt
hey ich hab eine bessere bombe gefunden
oder ich habe eine andere geile game lab
gefunden oder ich habe dies gefunden
oder das gefunden was uns auch mal
vorstellen könnte und in dem den typen
der das gebauter damit einfach wenn ihr
denkt hey ich hab auch was wir eventuell
vorstellen könnte schreibt für die
kommentare
oder macht das was euch spaß macht ich
würde mich über eine bewertung freuen
freunde lebt euer leben mach das was
spaß macht ja